the playstation 5 is launching with a
few exclusive games that i'm definitely
excited for
i'm talking about you miles morales but
there are even more big games coming to
the console beyond the holiday period
here are 11 of the biggest playstation 5
games you should look out for in 2021
as announced at the playstation 5
showcase stream sony's santa monica
studio
is back at it again with a follow-up to
the 2018
god of war the teaser trailer for god of
war ragnarok was
well definitely a tease showing only the
game's logo but that's not stopping fans
from trying to decipher the secrets it
may hold
anyway on top of that delicious tease in
2018's post-credits sequence
a user on reddit analyzed the writing in
the ragnarok trailer which may hint at a
significant role for freya in the sequel
this makes sense if you think about how
things unfolded the last time we saw her
there were a lot of unanswered questions
and
even unentered realms in ragnarok's
predecessor that may be explored in the
sequel but we don't know much about the
game just yet
but kratos is back and that's enough of
a reason for me to keep my eyes on it
also back is eloy in horizon forbidden
west where she'll be navigating a new
larger world while finding a way to stop
a mysterious crimson blight from
destroying the land and all of those
within it the beautiful cinematic
trailer for the horizon zero dawn sequel
showed off a few recognizable locations
like the golden gate bridge
and the grand canyon naturally they were
under some very post-apocalyptic
circumstances to further highlight that
the story will be on the west coast
of a far future america specifically
places that were once california
nevada and more we also see a lot of
exploration on land and
even more underwater which adds another
element to the depth of the game
and of course it's only right that in
this new land we'll also be facing
some new machine threats kinah bridge of
spirits was originally scheduled for
release this year but it got delayed to
2021
this new third person action adventure
game is developed by ember lab
the same people who made the amazing
majora's mask fan film terrible fate so
it's no surprise that the trailer and
footage shown so far for bridge of
spirits is just as
full of atmosphere you play as a young
spirit guide named kina who's looking
for answers about a forgotten village
and a strange curse
he'll build a team of adorable tiny
spirit companions called rot that are
scattered throughout the land
these creatures will help you gain
abilities alter your environment and so
much more you will have to make use of
the fast-paced combat to defeat trapped
and corrupted spirits to help them move
on as you try to restore this
once majestic world ghostwire tokyo is a
first-person action adventure game where
99
of tokyo's population has vanished and
it's up to you to fight the supernatural
forces that caused it
the combat has been described as karate
meets magic as you use a series of
intricate martial arts inspired hand
gestures to cast spectral abilities and
take down various paranormal threats
from what we've seen so far you'll be
able to wield fire water and electrical
magic attacks along with a boat when
revealed in 2019
it was made clear that ghostwire isn't
like the survival horror games that
tango gameworks is known for but will
definitely still have some eerie
elements in the world
the game's combat director sinichirohara
has previously worked on doom 2016 more
specifically
the push forward combat and the glory
kill system so that might give you an
idea of what to expect
all in all i think kyra said it best
when he said we want the player to feel
like a badass
spellcasting high-tech ninja exorcist
defeating countless spirits
return is a third-person sci-fi shooter
with a few rogue-like elements where you
play as a space pilot who gets stranded
on an alien planet to make matters worse
you're also stuck in a time loop the
trailer and a few screenshots captured
on the ps5 show a variety of alien
enemies in a dark and creepy planet it's
up to you to find a way to break the
cycle and survive
in the trailer the main character says
with every death the world changes which
may be a key factor in the gameplay
not much else has been shown since
returnal's debut in june but the flashy
weapons and abilities mixed with this
mysterious story definitely have me
interested
here's another time loop extravaganza
but on the complete
other side of the spectrum def loop is a
first-person action adventure game where
you play as colt
an assassin who washed up on the shore
of black reef and needs to defeat eight
targets
in 24 hours to break the time loop he's
stuck in
while it may sound easy you have to deal
with it all while being hunted by rival
assassin
juliana while cole is trying to break
the loop juliana wants to keep it intact
and you can even play as her
in death loop's multiplayer and
infiltrate the games of others but when
it comes to the main story the puzzle
lies within how
and when you kill your targets changing
the course of the loop to get your
targets in more
optimal scenarios and doing it all
within a single day
the combat footage we've seen shows a
variety of guns and mobility options
like sprinting and sliding but there are
also special abilities like a teleport
and
launching enemies with the flick of a
wrist giving me huge
dishonored vibes the gameplay tone and
story already have me picturing ways to
conquer black wreath
revealed at dc fandom in august gotham
nights is an open world action rpg
that is set in its own universe so not
the batman arkham canon and takes place
after the death of batman you can play
as batgirl
nightwing red hood and robin to fight
against a new underworld that has taken
over gotham city you can play the entire
story solo
or into player co-op and each character
will have their own progression paths to
level up
gameplay footage has already been shown
off which gives us a good in-depth look
at how missions can be approached
differently depending on your character
and your play style we even got a close
look at one of the villains you'll face
mr freeze each boss difficulty and fight
style will scale and change
based on your level so a fight at level
5 will be different than the same fight
at level 50.
gotham knights is starting to look like
a really meaty game and honestly
i can't wait to sink my teeth into it
this one is for all the fighting game
heads out there
guilty gears drive is the newest
installment in the guilty gear series
and
it's returning with its iconic intense
gameplay there are 12 confirmed
characters so far with returning
favorites like soul bad guy
faust and more on the roster a new
mechanic added in strive
is the wall hit stick state where
certain attacks that you land on your
opponent near a wall will cause them to
stick to and slide down the wall itself
in this state you have a chance to break
the wall and transition the stage
similar to other fighting games like
tekken this could lead to more damage or
other setups guilty gear strive also
introduces a brand new character named
nagoriyuki who is a vampire with a
number
of unique and powerful abilities that he
uses alongside
a huge sword the sixth main installment
to the far cry series arrives in
february 2021 and is set in the
fictional country
of yara your goal is to take down yara's
dictator anton castillo who might look
familiar to you if you're a fan of
breaking bad
this first person shooter lets you play
as a gorilla fighter trying to take down
casio and his regime
castillo's son diego is another main
character in far cry 6.
another important detail is that the
thanks for hire system
is back in the form of amigos for hire
and i am
100 prepared to protect chirizo at all
cost
his tiny wheelchair is filled with ammo
and scopes and other things that will
assist you in combat
cd projekt red has announced that the
witcher 3 wild hunt is making its way to
next gen
if you already own it on ps4 or xbox one
you'll even get a free upgrade
the next gen edition will include ray
tracing faster loading
times and other improvements for not
only the base game but also both
expansions
and all extra content gta 5
may be 7 years old but it's still making
its way to the new consoles
playstation users get some special perks
for gta online such as a million in-game
bucks for every month you play gta 5 on
ps4
until it's released on ps5 you'll even
get to play gta online for free with a
ps plus membership for three months when
it's released the new version of gta 5
will have a range of technical
improvements
visual upgrades and performance
enhancements to take full advantage of
the latest hardware
that's 11 of the biggest games headed to
your playstation 5
next year which one are you looking
forward to the most let us know in the
comments and if you want to stay up to
date on more ps5 news and content then
be sure to keep your eyes peeled to the
gamespot youtube channel
you